[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
round four of the spring classic here in
st. Louis grandmaster jeffrey jean
corner grandmaster surya Ganguly to
cement his lead in Group A plus grand
master Yao's era book led an
overwhelming storm of heavies against
Cuban grandmaster Lazaro presume in
Group B with his queen poised to pick
off international master Jack suit and
Bulli axe pieces in a hurry grandmaster
JJ Ali mirandy allowed himself to stay
in contention with a win at the halfway
point which players can stay afloat
coverage of round five starts now
with over $30,000 in pride on the line
20 international chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2018
spring chess classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome to st.
Louis for coverage of round five of
today's second most notable tournament
in the world consignment and this is if
I Tommy namer
and we are here with the 2018 spring at
chess classic and we're halfway through
vitaliy round five of nine yeah this is
the hump round yes just in between in
the middle yes so after we're over the
hump it's all downhill from here
hopefully not though that we have a lot
of fun still to come we have one result
in so far but before we get ahead of
ourselves let's take a look at what
happened last night in Group A yeah so
we have the three draws Sam chenkin
drawing with the white pieces against
Romain Edouard version of Cobian drew
against Alex only shook and dyrus words
draw against Alex epitope but we did
have two decisive results and we
actually black one in both of those
games Jeffrey's on beat so I can Gudi
and Yara terrible beat Lazaro bruising
and that's easy Geoffrey Zhang in the
lead and let's take a look at the entire
field as they stand after four rounds
have been played yeah so it looks like
Geoffrey Zhang is still in the lead with
three points after them we have
Alexander initial and the erosion a
carbon with a two and a half points each
then we have a few players or two points
and a point and a half as well pretty
close still pretty close indeed and
important to mention that Alexander
ownership has just drawn his game with
Sam Shanklin and so that means that
ownership is now at least temporarily at
the top with Geoffrey Zhang and as for
the other side of the room the B group
the results last night are as follows
and we were not aware of these before we
went off the air and now for the first
time we can show them to you oh look at
that so ng go is drew viktor makarov ski
actually chandra a Drupa dr. Kelly pan
Aaron grubens kid drew against Alexander
of fear and JJ variety warned with white
pieces against Jack's team you luck and
a wonder Liang lost to Melek
and this puts action Chandra the 19 year
old from here in st. Louis originally
from Jersey in the lead and this is his
tournament you know this is his
tournament to win for sure but it's
certainly not over like we said we have
four more rounds to go
yeah it looks like in both filaments we
have two youngsters leaving it hmm very
interesting and after that we have two
people with two and a half points that's
true very true indeed and now the game
is going on right now at us chess champs
calm are as follows in Group A the big
group the Masters here we are yeah we
have a game master domain eduarda
playing as Dario spirits game s Alex
Alex Alisha playing and Sam Shanklin
yellow jelly book is playing against
vara Coby on Jefferson against Lazaro
Brazil and Alex epitope is playing
against Surya Ganguly yeah and Jeffrey
Zhang against Lazaro Brazil is what I
would call the game of the day I think
that is a very intriguing matchup indeed
and the question remains can Lazaro
burrs own a halt Zhang's progress here
his momentum mm-hmm yeah okay and as for
the group B pairings here's what's
happening right now at us chess champs
calm all of these games are still in
progress and yes we can show them all to
you today yeah we have an example fear
against under Gaurav it's a - O'Connor
converse Erin grab insky medication
versus Akshay Chandra Jeff September
luck against a1 delaying and become a
collapse key against JJ more Andy and I
think it's quite obvious what the game
to watch in this round has to be two of
the top three players here in fact
Kashian is tied for second third place
and action Chandra in the lead this is
gonna be a big game in the overall
results of this tournament so will be
fun - yeah so remember this is the hump
hump round we're just in the middle of a
tournament which means that probably
players on the bottom of the list will
try to risk it to get to the top and the
players or the top of the
we'll probably just stay calm and and
secure the advantage one of the most
overused cliches that we have on these
broadcasts I admit it is blood on the
board but does that mean we could see
blood on the board yeah I think one
thing we did see it but it wasn't a
chest hug if I was it someone busted
their finger open while they're in a
chess club Wesley so thank you Danny
Wesley so busted his finger open I think
it was at the it was at the sink heel
cup or the rapid and blitz one of them I
think it was like a blitz and they're
playing so fast and they're just
smashing those clots been trying to
break them that yeah they're they broke
the fingers but yeah we don't have it
right now my staff was rushing around it
yeah who knew okay the the tournament
format for this event is as follows we
have 210 player round robins an a field
and the B field as you saw the time
control is 90 minutes for 40 moves with
a 30 minute bonus for each clock after
move 40 and there is a 30-second
increment from move number one this
tournament will feature the 30 move no
draw rule which means that no player can
agree to a draw until after both players
thirtieth move allowing for more
fighting chess as well in this
tournament well let's take a look at the
schedule we are five of nine rounds
through each day we are gonna be with
you two and a half hours after the start
of the round each day starts at 1:00
p.m. but the last two rounds will begin
at 11:00 a.m. and you'll notice if you
look at your calendar that tomorrow is
daylight saving time yeah so we're gonna
go into daylight saving time we're gonna
move up an hour you're gonna lose an
hour of sleep and so tomorrow it's gonna
feel like we're on the air at 2:30 but
it will still be 3:30 yeah hopefully
everybody's said that long crocus
correctly yes hopefully indeed also to
note you don't need to worry about next
Thursday because there will be no
playoffs if for this tournament in the
event of a tie at the top they will
share the prizes and you know Batali
there's a lot going on here
ask do you have any predictions
predictions yes
predictions pain okay and here's the
prize fund for group a 22,000 dollars
total on the line and that's a nice
little breakdown right there yeah I mean
if first place will take six thousand
dollars and then second place until face
will take four thousand and three
thousand dollars
very nice prize fund especially
everybody gets get something yes
everyone goes home happy
well maybe that's a little bit of an
exaggeration you always want to win and
the prizes for Group B are as follows a
$14,000 total prize fund and it breaks
down as such yeah so even the friend of
B group first place with a nice four
thousand dollars twenty-five hundred and
two thousand for the second or third
place and again everybody gets something
and yeah as we say no pain no gain
yes it's a very rocky day here at the
st. Louis chess club Rocky Balboa that
is for all fans out there great great
movie masterpiece all right let's take a
look at some of the games I'd like to
look at the game of the day in Group A
I'm talking about Jeffrey Zhang and
Lazaro burrs own all right let's get to
the action so we have Jeffrey Zhang
against us our Bo zone
Jeff is playing with white pieces let's
see what we have here a quick assessment
of the position this boot looks pretty
close
even everybody has same material I'm not
sure how to assess it but to me it just
looks equal again I was saying that
those players on the top like Jeffrey
Zhang which is leading with the
three-point seat probably not he doesn't
want to take any risks I mean why why
should he take any risk I mean he's on
the top so we probably played pretty
safe we can look at the how he got to
this position really quick he thought
was played like did stuff with c5 which
means that he's playing the Sicilian
something more sharp obviously Brisson
is trying to take over the top d6 and B
Knight to f6 okay an interesting line
not taking on the four Bishop e5 check 9
F takes on d7 d5 white gets the summer
space advantage here c4 Bishop g7 we
have some peas development over here so
basically in those kind of structures
black is trying to push b5 attack on the
Queen side white would probably try to
maybe to push e5 or try to prevent
before playing a four we have some peace
development
91 lots of exchanges so far as you can
see everybody's just playing very very
safe some exchanges have happened taking
on d5 technically White's pawn structure
is supposed to be a bit better because
of the this point e5 again more space
this Beko pawn on d6 might become weak
at some point but really our white
cannot attack this pawn on d6 we had a
twin exchange this is one number 1999 to
d3 in 94 roof to C 1 and a 5 you know I
think that again in this position black
is the one who is playing for a win if
you can see those pawns are coming a4
probably not before but a4 and taking on
c1 c4 basically black is trying to
breach to bridge that that wall or of
pawns that white has over here if he
succeeds in opening up the B file
I feel like black has lots of chances
it looks like grey zone is as you can
see on all the camera he stood up just
stretching his legs looks like Jeff is
under some pressure over here it's
difficult to be on the top yes and you
know you can't what do you think of the
mindset of just drawing his way to the
end like well is it gonna work Mitali
you said there's no reason to fight
right now right
on top but not by a lot yeah yeah that's
true a good point I mean if it draws
this game he's probably still be on on
place one even though he might share
that spot but later on is I mean it
depends but I would think that just
drawing all of his games automatically
is not such a good technique he will
have to still show some fighting chess
which is going to be interesting and I
think that by the way there are just a
move number 22 and only 17 only about 20
minutes to each player and they are
going to time travel for sure yeah a
little bit and also to note about
Jeffrey's spot in this tournament
yesterday we talked a little bit about
the range of ratings in group a compared
to the range of ratings in Group B and
in a it's a lot closer
everyone is nearly on the same footing
here right so it's gonna be a lot closer
field I mean you could tell by looking
at the standings at us chess champs calm
that's the case so it's not totally
comfortable for Jeffrey not at all nice
so let's move on to the game of the day
in Group B welcome back could be right
yes in a long time all right and all
these meters and games going this is
great so we have we have medic catchy
odd against action Chandra action
Chandra is in the lead so let's look at
this position right now this is more of
it more much more imbalanced position I
would say first of all white king is on
f2 does not feel so safe however I do
like his rooks
I do like White Queen hunt on c4
attacking the stroke on c2 I do like the
bishop here I do like the knight and do
like the pawn here on d5
I do like White's pieces a bit more so
only if weif could just make one off
just to come
escaped back to his king I'm sure the
King had was forced to to go to f2 but
here I I do like White's position
however now what I'm thinking about
black is a pawn up almost almost forgot
about this pawn on g6 it looks doubled
so it's hard to see but like does have a
pawn up so it is very unbalanced Queen
is attacking the rook on a - black is
probably thinking about something like
where do I bring this whether I bring
this truck should I bring it to a for to
attack his Queen should I bring it - I
don't know aah just to make sure that I
defended the back rank or should I
maybe maybe try to play something like
Queen a8 and do something on the a file
although I don't really see a reason why
why black would do that because that's
gonna leave the King much much more
exposed interesting game let's look
let's see how the game started from the
beginning white played efore okay we
have not seen lots of Evil games in this
tournament
mostly d4 and c4 so maybe this is this
was kind of a medics preparation for
today's game and let's see if 593 96
Bishop to c4 Bishop c5 d3 we have the
goiter pianissimo which is very
fashionable nowadays Castle d6 sickly so
actually white and black are both fine
here
this is gonna relate to the Rui Lopez
technique
well why just gonna try to play D fall
at some point and my new villain with
the pieces so Bishop e5 was played night
is going eventually why did play d4
Knight goes to g6 d5 getting some space
especially for the 9 and c4 here is
where he got the pawn aha so here's
here's the moment well why I decided I'm
gonna
to have this a five bond but black
obviously does not give it for free is
gonna take on f2 King takes the roof
takes on a five it's it's difficult to
assess such a position right now it
looks like I think that black is fine
but also White is fine
we just have to go and see what happened
Queen d2 take take we got a few
exchanges rook takes it to Bishop 3626
Queen a4 white recognizes that black has
this pawn on the six which is a weakness
Queen afraid was played Queen c4 was the
last movie that was played and let's see
I think what if we have a few moves
played after 24 actually played the rook
to e8 bringing the room back to to the
defense of the back rank and Queen to c7
was played yeah I like this this Queen
on c7 I don't know if she's gonna stay
there for long but really she's putting
some pressure on the all those pieces
the bishop and the two pawns yeah I
think I think we're gonna see some
fireworks over here
good I'm looking forward to it yeah yeah
so again time pressure this has moved on
with 26 both of the players especially
action Chandler isn't looks like he's
getting there into time pressure you can
see him kind of moving around in his
chair thinking about the move I do think
that medic looks a little bit more
relaxed probably determined is that as I
can see just looking around but we are
definitely going to get back to this
game one of the games that maybe isn't
quite as even here is in Group E Victor
mikhalev ski and JJ a lemur on D alright
let's look at the pixels game
interesting to me
so if I remember correctly Victor a lost
yesterday
Victor actually yesterday drew his drill
right drew how did two rounds ago yes
lost assembly AK in the third round
right so it's gonna be a nice to see if
he can get his way back to the top of
the list so this is gonna be one of the
important games of the day as you can
see Victor decided to play c4 which is
the English defense and black played
this f5 move going to the Dutch the
English Dutch defence so g3 was played
this is a pretty pretty popular standard
piece development we have faint
chattering of both of the bishops white
decided not to play at the point of d4 I
think this would be kind of my choice
you know just to get more of a hold of
the center but it's just a taste
preference some people just prefer to
play d3 why it gets this a nice
structure it's almost looks like the
dragon it looks like the the white
dragon so very nice i get places with
black so a castle and out efore wow okay
so definitely why this thing you know
I'm gonna play this risky game over here
t6 we have a few exchanges here Castle
96 b3 9 SF 4 Bishop f 7h for I
definitely think like white is is doing
everything possible to push however
quite I'm quite worried about this
diagonal opening it up this night here
so we'll see what happens is six nights
going back to eat 294
we have a few exchanges and now we had a
sacrifice so wife has sacrificed the
exchange in return he got nothing
well no pond is as far as I can see I
mean he right now black in this position
at least JJ Marathi has looked for for
for a bishop so yes so what the white
queen is pretty influential on this
diagonal and probably his ideas to play
something like Bishop to h6 and then
instead on the rock on their faith and
something to do something on on g7 so
rukhi 8 was played and an e5 d5 so now
that is I think there is a slight there
is a compensation for for white
definitely because of this Bishop on f7
defy was played take wing takes Bishop
g2 23 I also don't like this neither h5
it's kind of out of the game on the
bench rook e1 roti 893 there should be
eight
take so why does get a pawn here i
should be five-year whites whites
bishops are just so good coordinated
together
ninety-four we had a few moves back here
blacks idea is basically to push the
four and he needs to activate his Rose
because I mean he's kind of a rocker for
Bishop Bishop c6 is trying to exchange
the bishop and we are at this position
let me just refresh the board just to
make sure the well of you most-played
take 93 Queen to be two and here we are
a very very interesting position so what
do we have here
do we do we have the times correctly so
it looks like victim s Alaska has two
minutes that's what I have yeah those
times look correct to me actually
yeah and judge Hardy has forty minutes
that's wow that's that's a huge
advantage huge advantage so even though
materially looks like black is better
than maybe his position is better also
he has the day the time advantage so
right and this doesn't mean like he's
gonna run out of time right this isn't
sudden-death the players do get a thirty
second increment with each move the 30
seconds added on they get to keep it you
know it runs down the issue is with less
time to think
which mikhalev ski will be forced to
have your moves
if the excellence of your moves is going
to suffer right so that will you know
you'll be it move forty you'll have all
the time in the world again brand-new
half-hour exactly but your position will
be just toast yeah so right now viktor
makarov ski is focusing on the quantity
not on the quality needs to play lots
and i necessity yes
quality enough quality by necessity of
the clock yes all right
let's move that gonna flesh my page so
quick errand group in ski is in trouble
against priyadarshan canna pan in Group
B I know we've been looking a lot of
Group B here but I don't know it looks
like Aaron maybe not long for this round
okay maybe some breakthroughs lots of
pause that is true
either locked up I think I think so I
think I have some some some problems
here with the with a computer you know
it's it's a it's the weekend just the
weekend yeah he's you know his day off
I don't know well that's a tough one
yeah so I'll tell you what let's let's
go to a break and I'm gonna try to fix
this issue and if we can't we'll just
come back and talk about the candidates
exactly yeah all right so we can be back
in just a bit we're gonna try to clear
this computer issue up and then bring
you the rest of the games
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a trap here for those of you
who are new to chess it might look like
VA 3 is an illegal move here because
white mouse is prone to squares not one
but it still is something we call hustle
and you can do that but you have to do
it instantly you can't wait for a move I
played sake play King in seven kimchi -
and I'll try because y'all play four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed at length during the course of
my stay yeah he told me this is that do
you fight this was what I was kind of
hoping for because now I think he
practiced I know who Lawrence
this is not how chess works certainly
would be much much more fun if chess
actually work like this I don't think it
does well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
with the guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we're back just like that the magic
happened we have fixed the computer yes
okay welcome back to the spring chess
classic coverage of round number five my
name is Ben Simon and I have Italian
aimer yes and we were looking at some of
the games here and before we talk about
the the big main events that were
happening earlier on today in the other
part of the world I would like to look
at Priyadarshan Angra Pinsky this looks
like it's gonna be over pretty soon hmm
okay interesting - and come upon by the
way they're both close friends both
studying in the same school so I wonder
if they know both each other's style and
preparation it looks like pre-adoption
has we have again this this huge margin
between the time the time that fails
some of the clock so PD is with three
minutes and Aaron with 38 minutes
well PD is of course your buddy-buddy
nickname for priyadarshan I don't know
well enough to call him yeah so yeah
saves a lot of space you know ya feel
some forms okay so let's look at what
happens so in this position white has
looks pretty messy but this Queen on d7
looks pretty good is there is there a
reason why can't the Queen just take
take this this broken a7
huh it's a good question
it looks like that makes any difference
yeah it looks like I don't just like
this move see six as a last move and
he's giving up his rook okay
interesting interesting idea maybe a
bluff but maybe in the last resort but
what happens what to say what's this
idea if Y just takes this this pawn and
this rook I'm sorry is you can see that
you can only take on e6 but I mean why
it is just like two rules for Bishop and
this you know pawn is coming over
something that kind of no check and just
even even a7 I don't even think that
there is any chance for for perpetual
check or in this position yeah it's
almost doomed here for for black let's
see how how it happened we have D 46
Bishop to before by the way this
variation if I'm not mistaken it has a
very unique thing this is called the
kangaroo variation really yeah I've
never heard of it yeah I actually have
I'm going to be teaching a lecture here
at the st. Louis chess club okay about
chess openings with the most peculiar
names okay yeah so there's like the
Hedgehog the dragon have the kangaroo
yeah okay like we have just called the
kangaroo opening yes I've never heard
and that's probably because the the
bishop is just you know coming out to
before over here just jumping over and
92 was played 96-83 so let's see I guess
the kangaroo goes back jumps back for
her d6 Bishop d3 castle
I do like White's position I mean white
is head is having some space advantage
and looks like black wanted to exchange
some the Ducks club bishops Bishop h3
preventing whites from casting okay so
so far so good it's pretty even so let's
see what happened this was okay white
wanted to exchange the bishops okay King
takes f1 white loses the the option for
to castle but the king will probably
come to g2 g2 and it's going to feel
pretty safe here
in now Queenie eight I wonder if
completely hear something like f5 f5
probably not because if pawn takes I
cannot take on the fight because I'm
hanging in at night so this will not
work so that's probably why black played
this move 28 to defend the night h4
Bishop to h6 Queen c2 King h8 g4 wow
what a turn of events as I said I mean
those players on the bottom of the
standing lists are going to fight very
ferociously but they have nothing to
lose so let's see what happens so
suddenly white is the one who's
attacking on the King side g4 Knight f4
so far so good night g2 Queen d7 f3 rook
ae8 h5 I wonder you know still I have a
feeling that this Rokon f8 just aligned
over the king on f1 and really black
should probably try to open up the F
file if it doesn't then there is no
counter play for black so I wonder if
likely just waited too long to make this
this to work and now white is the one
who is opening at the H file very
exciting game Bishop g5 and now Knight
takes e4 pawn takes a 4 okay but now
white will have the H file and this
diagonal looking over this King and look
at that once black
took on therefore that is it that is
fixed that is it there's no way that
black is ever going to open up this F
file well not never but it's all be
super difficult for black to to open
this up so now as we said Y is going to
use this diagonal and now I like more
and more White's
position especially it letting this make
this this diagonal is very very strong
for white f6 Knight and d4 Knight is
coming here to e6 95 is stopping the
octopus from carrying 36 Queen to c2
preparing before Queen f7 b4 and now
white is taking they can end
why does put it at only 6 and I gotta
say it's it's a very painful sight to
see for blackness this Knight coming
only 6 and yeah as you can see this is
well black decided ok I don't want this
to play with it's not only 6 that's
that's gonna be impossible for me so he
decides to sacrifice but I don't think
that this is going to help him why it
just now tries to activate his rooks and
expose the position opened up the files
with a 65 second everything Queen d7
gets in there and now black decides you
know what I was doing you know my bishop
is hanging here on e7 my the queen is
coming here to to c8 how am i defending
anything and playing c6 wow that's
that's why I call all in Queen takes 187
let's see let's afresh the board real
quick
probably a few gain most rotate c6 he
did not take the rock wow he did not oh
so pretty he decides not to take the
rock and plays Queen to c8 still looks
pretty winning and I rook takes on v6r
okay he's black really does not like
this district of a please take my room
yes it's like what is going on here and
now PT is thinking about this I mean
what is going on here why so again if
white if I just take this rope the only
option for black would be to take this
pawn and try somehow to check with the
Queen on c4 and then somehow to bring
the coup the Queen somewhere here on c2
and c1 and perpetual check but I mean
remember this is why to move and I don't
even see how to okay let's try to make
this move Queen takes c6 Quinta c4 check
came to g1 went to d4 check can I escape
the chest check and king to h3 okay so
now normal checks but what if the Queen
comes for example the here to f2 I want
to checkmate white on g3 but now it is
white wolf and now all the pieces are
coming together Queen h6 probably our
take on h7 yeah it looks it looks like
to me that the Queen here and the rope
wouldn't have no problems in to decide
the game I think a few more games well
throw moves no I just I just so pity
just lays his hand yeah that's where we
are right now
both of these players aren't in the best
of positions in this event so far pre
Darshan's drawn all of us games means
decent grab in ski actually he's sitting
at minus 2 but remember curb in ski was
the last-minute replacement
it took the event on two or three days
notice replacing grandmaster james tar
jim so still being in the lowest rated
rated player in the field who knows how
much time he had to actually study up on
his opponents probably knows more about
priyadarshan than others because as you
said they are friends so intriguing we
expect priyadarshan to take this one in
in a short amount of time I'd say yeah
and don't forget that well not only Erin
but also PD Deb but that was still in
school still
have the finals and all the homework and
brother papers not so easy to combine
chess and it's not and the group a is
yaro zero book was in here yesterday and
I think you said what was your
preparation like and he said yeah I
didn't prepare yeah just have to do my
homework the game is over and you saw
the handshake right there priyadarshan
can of man has gotten the full point in
Group E we have several other results
for you while we were talking
Roman Edouard and Dario spirits in Group
A have drawn along with ona shooken
Shanklin their draw which happened right
as we went on the air in Group B our
game of the day milik Tatiana and akshat
Chandra that game is a draw
we took a glance of that it looked like
it might end up that way and now I'm
just I'm just looking for some lopsided
games because I don't want to miss any
of any decisive ones alexander fear and
andre corabeth's sticks out here in
group b look at that and hopefully we
can we can get pd in here too just to
ask him what was his population and you
know he won the game against Aaron he
did not take the rook he did nothing he
refused to take the rook four three
three moves even he even the the Queen
won't wait on d7 and that's well Alan
said okay I cannot I cannot stand that
you can't just don't take my my gift and
I was like yes and I'm being told that
we are expecting a resignation shortly
from Mika Levski and a lemur on day a
lemur on D has made time control in
Group E but in a reservation is expected
shortly
that's look at let's look at that
we have lots of decisive game so they
going pretty quickly
you called it you called it you know
we're gonna see more desperation if it
you know I don't want to be too dramatic
here but more desperation more
risk-taking right there nothing to lose
that's let's play some fun chess and yes
so let's look at all right Andre corvatz
has defeated Alexander fear that game is
now over we talked to Andre earlier on
in this event mm-hmm if we could I mean
I'd like to talk to priyadarshan yeah he
could Canada if we could get
priyadarshan down here that would be
wonderful
yeah and looks like if Victor
Michalowski will win which he probably
will because he's just almost just a
clean piece up it's gonna be interesting
to talk to him as well yes for sure you
know I have the toughest time getting
shots of him in the tournament hall when
I'm up there I go up there at the
beginning of the round I have a camera
that's when I do the intro yeah and he's
a lot of players you know they make a
few moves and they get up and if we get
some tea or coffee yeah he is up as much
as possible the guy does not like to sit
down at least in the opening so it's
tough to get shots of the Israeli
Grandmaster Victor Lipsky because he's
very tall so it supposed to be easier to
get some shots on him right anyway
oh yeah so that looks like that little
they just made move number 40 and I have
to say that probably something happened
you know that that time we said that
that time pressure probably the last 10
moves is what well well Y got the the
upper hand and I think that now JJ
Miranda if you look at the camera on the
video he just thinks to himself you know
I mean I have an hour and Victor has
half half an hour but he's a piece up do
I really want to continue here you know
I mean I have another game to play
tomorrow should I
continue because before that he just
wanted to make at the time control to
get another half an hour but it looks
like he made a move and so he keeps
fighting
I like the fighting side work c3 or
something rogue seeing the king let's
let's see so we have some some moves
coming in 97 and rooks III yeah just
just make a check but probably the King
is probably gonna go to f4 and although
even even though black has a pawn for
the night this one and h7 is such a huge
weakness and the rook is gonna come here
to h1 attack this pawn on H on h7 and
really we don't have I don't see a plan
for black I mean the route can come to
a3 try to get this pollinate too but I
think that the game is going to be
finished pretty decisively I mean there
is no I mean the knight cannot be
restricted or captured and I can always
go back to the six yeah I would I would
say that Victor will probably win this
game who do we have left or the only
game at section B that we have left is a
wonder Liang thing against Jack Istanbul
DIAC let's look at what it's good what
is going on here yeah also a pretty
complicated position they are at would
number 27 and again jack has only three
minutes and I wonder has 11 minutes so
they are both in time pressure white is
a pawn up but this King feels a little
bit lonely here especially the Queen on
the 5 is pretty active so I'm not sure
which side I would choose to be honest
maybe just because of the maybe just
because of the time I would maybe choose
black just to give myself some time
because I think probably something like
Queen h3 is coming and white is gonna
have some troubles
on the h2 square and so I'm not sure
what would be the result in this game
let's look at some old games let's look
at tally in Group A euro share a book
and Akopian it says they've drawn I
don't know if that's the correct result
if you want to take a glance at that
just for a moment
all right Yara is Arabic against
Aboriginal Cobian that's look let's look
at this one how how it happened here so
this was the final position go into h1
check King and there was a perpetual
check I wonder if the King could have
made go forward somewhere else going to
be one came to h3 I wonder so what do we
have here so black how many points we
have a six points for white and we have
six points for black very complicated
game position to be honest it to assess
this probably came from the French if
this would be my bet
but yeah so apparently they just drew
and and we will see them coming coming
back okay so at this moment I'm proud
and to have a guest here I appeared on
hey yeah I was just saying to everybody
that we call the PD yeah I was saying
that it's much it's much easier to for
the forest public just to put some video
that was mine today this is cafeteria
and they said PD they called me speedy
for the first time PD this video
new nickname so congratulations on you
win today
you beat your team member yeah but as we
say it's only business all right so
let's let's look at the game I assume
that you prepared a little bit yeah
follow the game let's look at the game
how the game went from the beginning I
assume pretty confidence yeah I played
before I mean I normally don't play
before but I found that he goes into
this kind of a BOGO Indian but by e6
Mordor so there was some final answers
that I thought I could explore it if I
go to this motor yeah that's why I went
for six I played see for it yeah I
remember when our plate I was playing
around here used to play the French so
the idea of playing Ecco so early is
that if white plays d4 it can get you
into the French but you said no we ain't
no French today so you played c4 and
Bishop before and now I was telling Ben
that I think this relation is called the
kangaroo variation I thought I thought
it was called the Charis some sort of
care system I believe yeah I guess I
just I just like you know just to invent
some some name for animals I thought
that this is okay so check so I assumed
this maybe surprised you a little bit no
not really I had this prepared with
Bishop b4 and I went ID - this was all
in my preparation and then even I'd have
683 Bishop e7 e 4 and here he was
expecting him to go defy because this is
basically BOGO Indian just that I don't
have him committed Knight gf3 it that's
the whole difference so there are some
lines where I can go a five-night and 37
and Queen g4 which makes a very critical
difference and like there's only like
three games and databases if you he
still fast poses to the French almost
looks like the French here yeah but it
does look like what usually has a little
bit of area some dangerous attack on the
Kings side exactly I mean I spent like
one hour looking at this pushing rate
cuts I got some idea so I thought okay I
can go into this but then he surprised
me playing d6 which he normally does not
go when he plays the book or Indian so
here I decided okay I don't
a new position for me I don't know
anything so it'll start thinking and
then I realized I don't want to
transpose into a burger and then maybe
he has some similarity with that so I
just had to go night to eat to it then
so I first played Bishop d3 and then
after this move the six pretty fast I
mean he normally plays very fast he
played it fast I don't know we got some
ideas on d6 I just played Bishop b3 and
then castles like how do you how do you
usually approach such such such fast
players I mean that do you change
anything they just try to fat to play
fast against them just to you know to
match the style well they just keep it
calm last time I played out and I tried
to match the style and didn't go well I
just made a draw and like the better
position so this time I was like I'll
just like sit and like spend all my time
on the clock and you know like it
doesn't matter how fast he plays I'll
play in my own paint advice when I was
when I was a kid that was always when
somebody was playing fast against me I
had to play like because almost like an
magic a race is gonna play faster but
get advice from PD over here you know
just stay calm and just calculate the
variations because now certain lines I
thought if black goes defy and followed
with Bishop g4 I have f3 but the finite
was on f3 then he would be able to
exchange so in case yeah Bishop you know
if my knight was on f3 he could take
Bishop takes f3 and yeah can I get rid
of this kind of you know to e5 and he
played a 5 here yeah here I cannot rush
then played b3 I think it was not
necessary should I just Castle I would
say it's a dubious move looks like a
better version of the King's Indian for
you because this Bishop maybe not on g6
I'm not sure if it's I think it's like a
World Indians or whatever they call it
yeah I don't know the exact name but
I've definitely felt which was a great
version for me to get like this question
with the opening but then I started
playing very bad for the next few moves
I was like I don't really like my
position like 10 five six most later
so yeah b3 and then obviously the idea
of them was to go a4 and you know
be somewhat safer that's why I went be
three right and so that I don't give him
an outpost and here even Knight h5 and
here I start becoming very creative and
played very weird Mo's which I'm pretty
sure computer not a pro Evan Knight up
one night f1 and ideas so the idea is to
go night III and kind of stop f5 that's
one and also in certain lines I had
night FG 3 so if he plays Knight H die
g3 I take with H pawn and I don't short
castle but I just try to attack on the
h5 yeah maybe even keeping you King in
the Sun yeah exactly keep the King maybe
I could even long castle in some
positions in these you know it's it's
it's kind of like a trend I see more and
more people especially high rated people
who do not castle attack on the H file
the eight files yeah everything what we
are teaching it against it right because
every time we have a new students we're
trying to teach the castle develop the
pieces and some of the he would maneuver
around
yeah but the position is closed here so
it's not really needed to castle and if
it's open position yeah it's riskier
that's what you see actually his film
was late from this game I had there like
huge issues with my King right so stick
to your basics is better version and
what I did I say yeah
93 and then he played he went g6 I think
he kind of equalized or maybe like
getting close to equality and g3 I have
no idea why I have played this move I
just thought was this is going to attack
but nothing happened he went Bishop h3
which i think is a very strong yeah so
how I please prevents you from castling
63 go to castle in this position have
some problems to solve also you also
stop h4 which was one of my ideas
potentially so yeah here even Knight c3
because my original idea was I thought
somehow I could trap the bishop on h3
but the deeper I thought about this
position I realized it's not going to
happen so when even Knight a six
yeah my first idea was to go g4 here mmm
and then go Queen f3 like Knight f4 and
Queen f3 and things like that but
obviously here I can't go immediately
lose the bishop on d3 but I can only
kind of pull back c2 Queen f3
but then obviously has like moves like
h5 and get rid of like open up you know
the
file for the bishop and all so anyway
the bishop is protected by the yeah yeah
also not so easy to get this night over
there yeah so so what I thought was
instead of going G for immediately first
go up II to force the night to go to g7
then go G for this was my idea but then
I realized how's my queen going to come
to f3 I had to go again Bishop d3 and go
Queen f3
but by then you have Queen C 8 + f5 and
all that stuff so I realized okay this
is not going to happen so I thought I
was getting close to becoming worse so I
decided okay I'll play Bishop f4 at
least try to get my King to safety but I
know it was already very unhappy with my
position yeah yeah so he played which f1
King f1 and Queenie 8 which is also very
good more because he's threatening to F
yeah I remember when I was looking at
this position and I was discussing it
was like well this king is in front of
the rogue as know that the black just
needs to open up the F file and things
will go very suffer but you cannot play
a5 immediately because he's gonna lose
the night yeah that's why yeah and the
funny line is if I play fi duppy 3 after
a 5 he takes a 5 Bishop takes c3 Bishop
takes in Peru cafe I have g4 so here and
win the piece so he has to go Queen e8 h
for Bishop h6 and here and also there
was honor again we should eat three
possible here which was interesting we
should take c3 Bishop e3 f5 e f5 he
could take a G or ruk ruk f5 is g4
Knight g3 King g2 Knight h1g FA and then
I distract there in this nice they stay
and the night astray in this line so but
he could take with a Jeep on and I think
that's just unclear here at this point I
mean I don't know I think this was
probably did the best bet for black to
play because then he may may know bring
his Queen and the rook comes to e8 and
he has some f4 ideas yeah so that was
probably the critical moment at here I
think there was one more critical moment
like two three mostly it like the next
morally in this game so create and also
share I was down and clogged by like 20
minutes or so it's like good yeah it's
okay everybody who's plays against Aaron
they're all down no he had somebody with
time against their so H for Bishop
eight-six and I played Queen Sita
because there was no other good way for
me to stop f5 and I thought the system
and here was the most critical moment of
the game where he made a huge mistake I
would say King h8 he had to go Knight
see fire and I think he maintains his
advantage shirt the idea of night see
phase one is a forest coming and if
something similar to game happens if I
go g4 yes Knight f4 and then the knight
can jump to d3
that's the critical variation and also
sometimes when I go a if he goes a for
beef if I go before yes night b3 and
take 1 c1 and take on e3 with a bishop
in certain lines I see yeah yeah and I
spent like 40 minutes on playing Queen
c2 because I just didn't like my
position but I had to accept that time
verse so here are mentally I was like
okay if I take a draw I'm happy but
there's only more 17 so I need to thirty
moves I need to keep the position close
that was what I was it was going on in
my mind that this energy yeah and yeah
yeah I get with the 95 just to small
more logical just to bring another piece
into the game so yeah so guys just play
more naturally right well Prince away
King h8 is probably preparing here five
but also put his King on this diagonal
which became very weak and also the I
think the bigger than that is that there
it's on the H file because later on when
you saw I played g4 h5
it came came in the pin that was the
bigger should than the you know the
Bishop b2 to a tag now right yeah I was
mentioning that who who is gonna open
their the file who's gonna strip who
first on the F file on the H file to pay
g4 very nice move can I do
ninety-two then you want to choose yeah
and here again I thought he could have
gone nights ePHI Queen d7 bit surprised
me because once again the idea of night
c5 is like potentially the night comes
to d3 one of the nights I'm right there
yes f3 and then here he went Roque 8
which kind of surprised me because I
don't have a small H 5 so still there is
no f5 here not even if it goes f5 here
the idea is e take left 5 G takes f 5
the shirt takes F 4 Bishop takes F 4 and
I play G 5 so nice no I take on f4 and I
think this is my night comes to e2 but I
mean I think it's still unclear maybe
white is slightly better and I - for AF
492 and I can play some Queen C 3 so I
saw this portion of Queen g7 here and
then I can as I kind of assess this
position is most probably unclear but
not I'm not worth any more right yeah
the other thing that's worse but it's
still better than watch economy game
yeah exactly this was definitely way
better than what he got in the game
yeah after rook e8 h 5 here you should
have gone g5 his last tried to keep the
game you know in equal terms but after
Bishop he found clearly better yeah I
think after the game I was talking to me
he was more worried that a good IDE 3
Knight f5 he had gone g5 but I was
telling him that I haven't I don't have
fair you have an ID on f4 it's kind of
like equal so like 93 Bishop g7 Knight
f5 Bishop f6 and then hezbi up gets out
and he should try to go some c6 b5 break
but making is now safe because I blows
the King side yeah yesterday there was
also two players who had those nights
over here and I was mentioning it looks
like a beauty contest whose night is
better so yeah this was his last chance
with you playing Bishop g5 and now
you're getting it's going like he went
yeah it's just pushing got very rapidly
and he also started I kind of gave up to
like him like sense like he didn't think
deeply he should have here like one hour
and I had like five minutes with like 14
rows to me oh baby he plays on time
he could have but the I mean here just
like position is closed so there's not a
lot of tactics like he said like one for
night c5 he maybe I thought it was to go
94 okay and also obviously stopping my
b4 with 94 so I just like out like Queen
c2 and now a different birthday for any
foreigners yeah and still very
impressive that you're playing all this
game with his King on the phone and
follow the route but after he's captured
on there for that then that's it right
yeah the father is locked and I'm very
happy after before and you took and
after night take came too easy so pretty
yeah I'll show you you know that you're
gonna win exactly here okay head just a
debate if I de Graaff five or six and if
I looked optimally more pleasing because
it's a great outpost but I decided you
know materialist material with low time
I could just like you know how many
extremity who gives me more confidence
than because I saw some lines with 95
Bishop e5 c5 here and this Bishop is
kind of getting out of g5 which is
pretty bad right now but after a fee fie
some moves like Bishop d8 can come so I
thought maybe has some chances way to
give him just take the material and then
try to convert later on right yeah good
choice so 96 and here he does - I was
actually if you go back the two most
instead of F g6 I was surprised he took
with the Queen he could have taken with
the H pawn and that was still
interesting cuz Queen h2 Queen g7
yeah here no pre go back a move to Mo's
alright are so when he took her the
Queen's yeah he could take with the H
pawn there was this line Queen h2 Queen
g7 96
I thought this kind of maybe gave him
some more chances than but took it's not
a huge one but I thought this was
slightly better but not a huge
difference yeah okay so he took with the
Queen and then this Bishop on c5 just
was kind of yeah dead that's the biggest
issue yes after Queen g6 9656 and yeah I
just decide to simplify and go Queen d3
he goes pin e6 our Queen d5 decided that
right and then but he decided I mean he
kind of forced me to open the position
now tell us about you know the endgame
it was it was so funny because Queen d7
and I I looked at the position on its
first time it was like c6 and was that
okay let's assess this position I was
like wait a second can't you just take
the phone on a seven do we have the
right position
yeah and I was like wait a second c6 was
them that was the last move even like
what is going on here so so what happens
is this was moved 38 and I had two
minutes on the clock and I started
thinking Queen a7 Queen e6 and if I go
Queen B a check let's say yes Bishop f8
and then I wasn't really sure how my
Queen could come and defend for example
if I let's say play a seventh most all
it should be winning I just didn't
ordered you take this chance to the 87
Quincy four check King G to Queen e2
checking h3 Queen f3 king h4 Queen g3
King h5 should be renamed my King walks
to h5 and I'm like why to take honest
rigorous I mean I have the game in my
completely in my control but this is
like even if I'm winning still I'm
giving him one or two slight hope right
just quite to give him that
oh so I decided let me just hold the e6
pawn which is the most critical thing
and then finally he again offered me the
route next move right please go Queen d7
because now it was fun if he goes route
k7 after the Queen d7 I just taking a
seven Queenie six Queen e7 Queen e7 b7
so that was what I was like I just
wanted to like you know not I don't want
the bow making from f1 let it stay there
nice so very nice swing had you know
hoping tomorrow
I think I'm playing Alexander fear okay
so tough tough nature how are you how
are you managing school and and chess
this is my last semester in school it's
kind of you know like just two more
months a lot of things about us what
what's your major in I'm doing a
master's in management and leadership
and then I had an undergrad in marketing
so some
in businesses all right maybe some of
you knows one of those startups you're
gonna be a leader yeah so so good luck
if you're looking looking for a job or
anything yeah we have another guy coming
into the job market yeah yeah yeah we're
welcome so thank you so much for joining
us and good luck in the tournament and
we are going to go into a short
commercial break and stay with us
there's a weekend vacation
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you could fly to Venice
[Music]
or Paris
or even Copenhagen
you could fly all over the world but why
when you just come to st. Louis
your trip begins at explore st. Louis
calm a moment comes in chess when you
need to test yourself at a different
level chess 24 premium offers the tools
that you need to reach your maximum
potential from hundreds of interactive
video lessons to becoming part of the
chess 24 community you can analyze with
friends or coach your students live you
get twenty four by seven coverage of
chess news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it botched
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
hello chess fans and welcome back to
coverage of round five of the 2018
spring chess classic my name is Ben
Simon and I'm about that I named her and
we want to thank priyadarshan campaign
for just coming in and giving that
wonderful interview it's great talking
with a guy like him he's a very friendly
dude I've known him around here st.
Louis for a few years now yeah of course
yeah he is actually one of my best
friends and he's originally from India
but he came here on a scholarship and
finishing his master's here and as we
are taking looks here at the fields
group a looks like it's gonna end up all
draws today there's still one game in
progress that's a Pathan and Ganguly and
it looks like an even end game yeah I'm
disappointed that was always looking for
some some old pain as I said yes no pain
today okay well group II might be a
slightly different story the entire
field is wrapped up for group B and we
do hope to have a we are told we're
gonna have victor mika Levski in here to
talk about his victory over JJ Ali
Mehran day he were just giving him a few
minutes to go over the game you know and
that's kind of important a lot of
players want a moment to go over the
game cuz they might have missed
something yeah yeah it's always
interesting to analyze with your
opponents yes while we're taking a
breather from the action let's talk
about what happened today in Berlin
Germany the opening day of the 2018
candidates tournament and for those of
you not in the know that is how we
determine who plays Magnus Carlsen for
the World Chess Championship late this
year
in London so in Berlin there is an
eighth player double round-robin
tournament all play all twice once with
each color and actually in this event we
have three Russians and we have two
Americans yeah and I don't I should have
looked this up I don't recall any time
in an eight-player candidates event it's
never happened where there have been two
Americans in the field yeah you
u.s. so Fabiano Cara Juana and Wesley so
are in this event and today actually
they played each other in Berlin now
this tournament because they have
similar they have like nationalities and
three Russians are two Americans those
players have been formulated to play
each other early on to avoid any of that
Fisher style collusion you know the
Soviet Union's colluding with each other
so so the Wesley and Fabiano meet first
and I believe they play again in round
eight there's gonna be 14 rounds at all
and we're telling you all about this
because even though that's in Europe and
we're here in st. Louis starting on
March 22nd round 10 of 14 we're going to
have coverage abbreviated coverage
starting at noon st. Louis time of the
2018 candidates tournament and by then
we will have kind of a picture of who's
the frontrunners in this event yeah yeah
definitely definitely interesting by the
way so today's so the participants we
have Aronian level Neronian we have
Bingley rain Khurana Fabiano's Wesley so
Sergei Kuryakin I'm Shaquille magma
media of the Vladimir Kramnik and
Alexander Greece shook today Levon
Aronian drew against ding Duran Khurana
fabiella beat with the white pieces
Wesley so Sergei Kuryakin lost to Sakuya
monomer with the arrow and Vladimir
Kramnik
beat with the white pieces Alexander Lee
shook by the way a volley mechanic he
was the wild-card which means that he
did not qualify to a tournament or
through a rating but he was actually was
picked by the organizers and it looks
like you know he's he's bringing it you
know he's showing showing his tanks for
for picking him by winning his first
game that was I was always wondering how
this qualification always works in order
to heal in st. Louis we have
and gain chest or some other tournaments
that their people are qualifying and so
how does that usually work so the World
Chess Championship goes back all the way
to the 19th century and ever since the
40s it's been sanctioned by fidei the
World Chess Federation the grand chests
were presented by st. Louis and London
and the teams in Brussels and Paris is
not that circuit is not directly
affiliated with the World Chess
Championship cycle LeGrande chest or
standings unfortunately have no bearing
on the world chess championship
qualification but fidei has their own
qualification first of all the runner-up
of the 2016 a match was Sergey Karjakin
right that match was in New York City
not a great setup there actually I'm
wearing my thing from that event so so
Sergey gets an automatic entry into the
field of 8 the top two finishers of the
World Cup which is that 128 player huge
knockout event aronia and Dean Blair in
that that's how they qualified the top
two finishers in the feed a growing prix
which is a series of tournaments similar
to the grand chest tour shakira mami
Dara and Alexander who shook and the top
two players with the highest average 20
17 feet high rating who played in the
World Cup or ground pre that we didn't
already mention the two Americans
Fabiano Cara Juana and Wesley so and
then Vladimir Kramnik gets the
organizers wild card so he becomes the
third Russian in the field and you were
telling telling the results with this
elite field my goodness there's three
decisive verses I know I know it's yeah
it's way it's very surprising but yeah
they they I want to fight for it for the
for the honor to play against Magnussen
Nelson one of the improvements in this
world championship cycle over the 2016
edition is there will be a playoff in
the case of a tie in the double
round-robin so two years ago I know the
fans in st. Louis definitely remember
and a lot of Americans as well Fabiano
Cara Juana and Sergey Karjakin were the
two top placers okay and it was in the
last round and
believe they were playing each other and
Cara Juana had to win if he tied he
would lose on the tiebreak system there
was no playoff so he had to take chances
that he wouldn't otherwise have taken
and hey the players knew about it it was
the nature of the tournament but who
doesn't like to see a playoff and I
think that would be very exciting to see
so here at the chess club we'll have the
18 broadcast I'm telling you Maurice
Ashley yasser sarah juan jen Shehadeh
and more they will be here in the studio
call in the action with a three-hour
delay so we'll be on the air at noon
central a st. Louis time three hours
after the events in Berlin get underway
and rounds 10 11 12 13 and the final
round 14 will be happening starting
March 22nd and an extra day maybe for
playoffs who knows yeah yeah I'm hoping
it's like some exciting matches and you
know 14 rounds that's a lot it's almost
like two lumens combined back-to-back 22
days I believe is the full length of
this thing it's it's a huge event but
there's there's nothing more prestigious
than being the classical world chess
champion such a legacy but to do that
you gotta beat Magnus Carlsen and to
even get there you've got to win this
grueling double round-robin candidates
tournament so we'll be presenting that
starting March 22nd let's take a very
short break and when we come back I
understand we are ready to talk to
grandmaster victor be cholesky the
Israeli competitor in this event
Group B so we'll be right back with
Victor
[Music]
[Music]
the question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like ba 3
is an illegal move here because Y
advances for two squares not one but
it's a little something we call all
person and you can do that you have to
do it instantly you can't wait for a
move like that say play King in seven
kimchi - and now try because yeah I'll
play four against Lawrence and now he's
going to play something against me which
we discussed at length during the course
of my steak yeah he told me this is that
fun
g5 this was what I was kind of hoping
for because now I think we finally know
who Lawrence this is not how chess works
certainly would be much much more funny
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does how maybe it does well
that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it
my quality of life has just gone
downhill tremendously because I'm
actually sharing the office with the guy
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello HS fans that welcome back to the
2008 18th spring chess classic this is
international master of Italian name er
and I'm here with gen master Victor
McCarthy from Israel and welcome to our
show
first of all congratulations on your win
today so yeah so I know I share no
victor form childhood i him and his
brother Alex mcclewsky I had a few chest
lessons from him and and Victor you are
still coaching right coaching and
novation chess it's a it's quite
difficult right to coach and play chess
at the same time yeah how things how
things in itself pretty pretty good the
sun is shining beautiful me and actually
form for myself I got married about a
year ago but delicious thank you me and
my wife and I we are playing planning
our wedding over there in September so
yeah so they excited yeah of course yeah
of course alright let's talk about you
win today you been JJ morandi with the
white pieces so let's look at the game
you start the both FIFO and English I
assume that you had lots of time to
prepare for the game yeah so f5 did that
did that surprise you and not really
yeah I expected either a 556 mm-hmm okay
so English part of my preparation yeah
okay so g3 so I assume that this is a
pretty common idea in the against the
tide show in the English - yeah - the
regular that ship is d4 if I won but
that wasn't in this game right actually
I was just mentioning I was looking at
your game I was like well maybe I would
say here d4 but you know it depends on
the style depend of on your mood just
repeat these three but but he surprised
me first okay I will say that this
structure that you have right now almost
looks like the white dragon in fact it
can transpose to the
if black plays d6 c5 it's 6:45 English
right right so many openings I mean who
is going to decide on the opening you
guys going back and forth okay great so
he cancelled and now II for here you
know when you play this movie for I was
I was saying that you're probably
playing for a win you know they gotta
take your risks right all right yeah
that's the spirit
that's the spirit and here he surprised
maybe see if I if I expected t5 because
he played like he took first in son
played c5 okay so instead of E 5 yeah
okay yeah so c5 you just castles in 96
and then I played the h3 it's a kind of
a prophylactic move yeah just to powers
the chief for square and also Blake
might have an idea of Bishop e6 followed
by Queen d7 just because the diagonal
just prevent this this cage to yep nice
so Bishop he sees that was played and I
have played Beasley yeah protection 27
and here he expected me to play King
gauge to but it was possible in fact but
I decided 94 is more interesting yeah
also I can do attacking the bishop
reveal and he goes back and then it
seems that I may have some problems with
the long diagonal but they just played
age for a modest play Bishop h3 right
interesting you will not do not afraid
of this
well I try to calculate and they didn't
see anything concrete for him right he
can always win in exchange he can even
take on e4 using I like it here even
here but I can take back with my knight
Bishop takes a1 and Knight takes e5 and
it looks very strong yeah another pond
yeah and they can get to e6
very nice okay so he played night age
five yeah he said after the game that he
just wanted it to be interesting it was
also like like it to be interesting
stuff is six and night f2e to so you
decided so you can take on H five
because if I take Bishop Syrians and
yeah it just throws more than an
exchange yeah this is too interesting
okay so night just made it he plays
Knight d4 it's the smallest force
because if he doesn't play it I play
Bishop II see he never gets to different
right Bishop III and did you have any
any other ideas like Bishop to b2 or but
I wanted to force night xe2
I see okay so Bishop III 98 c2 and now
he means an exchange but this looks
extremely adventurous public right I
didn't have to think twice yeah actually
when I was looking at this position I
thought that black is fine but
eventually I you know the game show that
this night and h5 feels a bit awkward
and your bishops are very good all the
dark scores are extremely weak so yeah
great positional sacrifice rook F to e8
yeah probably a little bit is because
his bishop who needs to get from me to
c6 at some point later on in the games
yeah
five nice nice smooth fixes the bishop
here yeah because if he manages to play
d5 then it's not so easy anymore d5 is
the simplest foursome quintics was back
to g2 his trick was that if I play
Knight c3 because Knight takes cheese
okay so I just protected the night and
now I can play Knight c3 because my
bishop is protected so Bishop eight now
he's trying to bring the bishop to c6
yeah so we see that the lost temple here
on only eight took the pawn here and the
idea was just to prevent Bishop sistex
okay the pole is just like okay and
let's run away I didn't care that much
about the poles but I wanted to keep my
Bishop and let him play Bishop very nice
very nice so Roxy yeah he's still trying
to play Bishop c6 and Bishop g5 the
point is to provoke as a new play group
the 7th and he is blocking the bishop
you even don't like this Bishop is
pretty bad and if I manage to keep nice
as a Rudy for was played those occasions
and he was trying at least somehow to
activate his pieces yeah now he wants to
play Bishop c6 so that's why 94 and the
point is if he plays Bishop c6 I play
Knight takes e5 and he loses zero
community for he was attacked
yeah ok so he played away to 7
Quincy won and now my idea is to play 96
and if he plays Bishop c6 I can take on
c5 okay because then his Bishop is
painting I see and that's why probably
he played c4 that's why he played c4
again he still wants to play Bishop d6
and he did play Bishop c6 of it I
usually after that can move yeah yeah
but now it's a with the cost of a pawn
yeah 93 is okay that's the practical
chance in my time you do did you expect
that no yeah yeah I expected mind you
see probably I can also take the night
but I wasn't that sure and did you say
it was just simply inches three okay -
it does look like he has some some
question here also takes me five so gets
messy yeah good decision
yeah I didn't want to complicate matters
when a queen bee - looks like a very
strong move because my circus queen bee
China you know in this tournament we
already saw a few just games somebody
offer the piece and people just don't
take it they win it's kind of kind of
strange I because in the chest you just
let it take take take and you just say
no no thank you
you don't have to write a check as you
have to take so queen bee to was played
in Ruby 7 again he you know he offers
there another piece because it doesn't
do it I just play queen bee check and
take it with a check be a queen takes
the seven check right and that's just
the worst
meeting a couple of more so that was his
only chance and room chief where I also
expected this idea and actually
threatening ID to check after a beef so
I just I give up this phone on f3 in
order to open the second drink it does
look like there is a lot of pressure
here on the King on the Kings side but
it's possible to calculate here it's not
too difficult so f3 Bishop f3 and then
in fact his rate is not that big I mean
he wants to play 92 but then I take with
zero and he needs another temple to
create something so I just played 96
creating a threat of Queen B check and
then a checkmate in a couple of moves so
if he found the Knights move King g7 I
didn't see this one but it doesn't
change that much
yeah there's no check because of the
patient yeah Wow very very brave but
yeah I guess it's works more yeah
because if 92 check can give to and no
more checks yeah and everything is
hanging yeah it just needs like me like
many maybe work one more piece Queen d7
that's it yeah that's that's the winning
move right after you after trade the
Queen's found a nice 390 it was probably
slightly inaccurate but I could have
done many things but here he played King
affinity and it turns out if I take the
pawns and only six and King g7 and my
net is in some trouble I also consider
it now g7 and then she plays kinga faith
if king of 76 check and he promotes but
King f8 and now if I play six
Roxas seven
I just just seven still kid takes and
dimension is a night to be trip Wow yeah
he actually after rook takes is seven
you don't have to take oh I can play 96
that's the theme of the tournament do
not take the pieces so you just played
King tonight get back from this now I
also have a threat to Brooke each one
yeah I was saying I was I was so
disposition and I was saying that you
know he was calculating and you just
passed them all number forty he's
probably thinking you know do I really
want to play another hour or should I
design because this poll annoyed
chairman is you know it's falling and so
I just continued a few more few checks
but really there's very nice game
congratulations and you play next all
right this is my spirit you know I'm not
sure I'm just gonna beat them come there
no population you know just one game
anything yeah yeah that's that's the
spirit you hopefully you enjoying your
stay here in st. Louis with lots of good
things to do yeah that's a good
restaurant so the weather looks to be a
little bit far for to fly from Israel as
I know probably a few flights but yeah
welcome my let me know if any questions
and so thank you so much for joining us
today and good luck in the rest of the
tournament and we are going to go into a
quick commercial break and stay with us
afterwards we will come back
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just twenty four premium membership
[Music]
I'm Mike Matheny whether you play chess
for fun or want to boost your child's
academic performance come visit the
Chess Club and scholastic center of st.
Louis right here in the chest capital of
the u.s. from a welcoming diverse
environment to a Scholastic outreach
program now in over 100 schools our
Center across from the world chess Hall
of Fame the Central West End has it all
so whether you've played for years or
never before we invite you to experience
all chess has to offer
hello and welcome back to st. Louis for
a coverage of round five of the 2018
spring chess classic I'm Ben Simon and I
thought na mele and we're here to wrap
up the show for you so we just have one
game still in progress that's been a
pretty good day we've been able to cover
everything we wanted to cover yeah and
the game still in progress is Alex EP
Tom and Surya Ganguly we do expect that
to be a draw which would in fact make
all of the games in Group A a drum and I
saw there were some commenters online
talking about a Kobe ins game with black
against euros Arabic that game was a
repetition it was a draw that has been
double checked with the arbiter drama so
what if your whether your final thoughts
on the round today Vitali yeah I mean it
looks like we had some fighting chess
but you know they just as we said the
players are on the a group just I think
so so close they're very strong players
so we see lots of drawers but we still
still still see some fighting chests I
mean we never see you know ten move draw
first of all just illegal but but still
we still see them fighting till the end
in the big group we did feel we did see
some decisive results some lots of nice
action over here it looks like the theme
of today is now is if they give it to
you do not take it okay let's take a
look at the live standings for Group A
and it like we said only one game
remaining and Jeffrey Jean still a half
point above everybody else all draws
though you know looks like that last
game is going to be a draw as well and
Group B we can show the complete
standings after round five all games
have finished there we go oh so we do
have a change on the top of the list so
action Chandra is still leading but to
him we have Andrew garbetts who is
joining him with three and a half points
and then we have many
kutcheon and Pierre - I'll come up with
three points so it's getting more and
more even although although all the rest
of the players they have two points so
there is some some margin between the
first four places in a lot in the last
six places still very close fight and
I'm not sure but I think that Akshat and
Andre did not there yet
so this is going to be an interesting
fight yeah absolutely the Belarusian
gore vets is one of the more quiet
competitors you know and here he is just
coming up the leaderboard tied for first
place now with the st. Louis and akshat
Chandra okay well that's gonna do it for
today remember to join us tomorrow the
round begins at 1:00 p.m. Central and we
go on the air at 3:30 but it is daylight
saving time so tonight if you have an
analog clock remember to line that
forward an hour before you go to bed and
we'll be on essentially what is well
twenty three hours later so we'll be on
an hour earlier guys so we'll see you
tomorrow
this production was produced by the
world's greatest B team Ryan Chester was
making sure the stream didn't drop today
Dennis LaRue was getting us interviews
Isaac's rants is on graphics and sound
our technical director is danny Machuca
my name is Ben Simon and I am Vitaly
namer and until tomorrow at 3:30 central
time we say so long from the Show Me
State
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you